the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi today we do a somewhat computational
bit and actually the lecture for today
is not nearly as difficult once you get
through the maze of symbolism as it is
to apply the material in other words
we're going to devote the next two units
of our course to this particular topic
which is known as the chain rule but
we'll give one lecture to cover both
units and again the idea is that it's
not so much that the concept becomes
more difficult as much as it is that you
must develop a certain amount of
dexterity keeping track of the various
partial derivatives and the like any
rate may be I think the best way is to
just barge in to a hypothetical
situation and see what the situation
really is the idea is essentially the
following we're given some functions say
W W is a function of say the three
independent variables x y and z now for
some reason or other which we won't
worry about right now it turns out that
x y and z are in turn conveniently
expressible in terms of the two
variables r and s in fact if you want a
physical interpretation of this you can
think of you know if x y and z are
functions of the two independent
variables r and s that means that we
have two degrees of freedom so we may
think of this as parametrically
representing the equation of a surface
and what we're talking about here is W
being a function of something in space
and asking what does W look like when
you restrict your space to a particular
surface I mean that's just a geometrical
interpretation that one could talk about
but the idea is the following after all
if W depends on x y and z and x y and z
each depend on R and s in particular
then it's clear that W itself
is some function of R and s where again
I use the usual notte
of using a G here rather than the F up
here to indicate that the relationship
between R and s which specifies W may
very well be a different algebraic
relationship than that which relates XY
and Z to give W but the point that we
have in mind is the following given that
W was a function of XY and Z given that
XY and z are functions of our and s
hence W as a function of R and s the
question that we asked in calculus of
several variables is first of all if we
can be sure that these were all
continuously differentiable functions
can we be sure that W will be a
continuously differentiable function of
R and s that's the first question and
the second question is okay assuming
that the answer to the first question is
in the affirmative that W is a
continuously differentiable function of
R and s how could we compute for example
the partial of W with respect to R
knowing all of the so-called obvious
other partial derivatives what do I mean
by that what would I mean is if you were
to look just at this equation just
looking at this equation what are the
obvious partial derivatives to take you
say well we'll take the partial of W
with respect to X the partial of W with
respect to Y and the partial of W with
respect to Z and if you were to look say
at this equation the natural thing to
ask is what is the partial of X with
respect to R what is the partial of X
with respect to s etc in other words
what we're saying is in this particular
problem we would like to figure out how
for example to compute the partial of W
with respect to R knowing that we have
at our disposal the partials of W with
respect to XY and Z the partials of X
and y with respect to XY and Z with
respect to R etcetera meaning we also
have the partials of XY and Z with
respect to theta before I go any further
notice by the way that if I left out
that phrase that we were talking about
in our last lecture continuously
differentiable notice that all of this
would make sense provided that the
derivatives existed
there was no place here do I make any
statement that the partials have to not
only exist but be continuous I never say
it at all this is what the problem is I
would like to use the chain rule do you
see why it's called the chain rule w is
a function of x y and z x y and z are
each functions of r and s now what I
claim is that not only is it possible to
do this
but the recipe for doing this is a very
very suggestive thing one which is very
very easy to remember once you see how
it's put together if you don't see how
it's put together the thing is just a
mess namely the claim is that the
partial of W with respect to R is the
Posche I'll just read it to you the
partial of W with respect to x times the
partial of X with respect to R plus the
partial of W with respect to Y times the
partial of Y with respect to R plus the
partial of W with respect to Z times the
partial of Z with respect to R as I say
if you try to memorize that it's a very
very nasty business but let's look at
this in three separate pieces
in a way can you sense that this is
nothing more than the change in W with
respect to our due to the change in X
alone in other words you're taking here
what the change in W do to X and
multiplying that by the change in X with
respect to R so this is the contribution
of the change in W with respect to R due
to X alone on the other hand this is the
partial of W with respect to R due to
the change in Y alone and this is the
partial of W with respect to R due to
the change in Z alone and since x y and
z are independent the change in X the
change in Y and the change in Z are also
independent variables consequently it
seems reasonable to assume that define
the total change of W with respect to R
we just add up all of the partial
contributions namely we take the partial
of W with respect to R due to X alone
add on to that the partial of W with
respect to R due to Y alone add on to
that the partial of W with respect to R
due to Z alone and that that sum should
be the total change in W with respect to
R treating s as a constant and by the
way let me point out a pitfall with this
notation you know we're so used to using
fractional notation here have you
noticed that if you're not careful here
you're almost tempted to cancel I don't
want to write this because you'll think
that it's the right way of doing it but
as always you say hey let's cancel the
partials with respect to X here let's
cancel the partials with respect to Y
here and let's cancel the partials with
respect to Z here by the way if you did
that notice what you would get is the
contradiction that the partial of W with
respect to R is equal to the partial of
W with respect to R plus the partial of
W with respect to R plus the partial of
W with respect to R in other words it
seems that you would get that the
partial of W with respect to R is always
3 times itself which is I hope a glaring
enough contradiction so I don't have to
go into any more detail about the
contradiction part notice again though
why I have made such a fetish
why I have made such a fetish over
labeling the variables notice that when
you're taking the partial of W with
respect to X you're assuming that y and
z are the variables that are being held
constant and when you're taking the
partial of X with respect to R its s
that you're assuming is being held
constant and as soon as you look at
these subscripts here somehow or other
that should put you on your guard to be
careful about crossing out because after
all the changes are being made with
respect to different sets of variables
at any rate this is the statement and my
other claim is that the proof follows
immediately from the main key theorem
that we stressed last time even though
we didn't prove it but we've had ample
exercises using this namely notice that
we have already seen that if W does
happen to be a continuously
differentiable function of x y and z
then delta w is the partial of w with
respect to x times Delta X plus the
partial of W with respect to Y times
Delta y plus the partial of W with
respect to Z times Delta Z plus an error
term and what is that error term it's k1
Delta X plus k2 Delta y plus k3 Delta Z
where k1 k2 and k3 all approach 0 as
Delta X Delta Y and Delta Z approach 0
now again the key step in all of this is
that this amount here I could always
call Delta W tan R as Professor Thomas
calls it for more than two variables
Delta W sub Lin Li n meaning that this
is a linear equation remember I've made
an abbreviation here these partials are
assumed to be evaluated at a particular
point that we're interested in but the
idea is granted that I can always call
this Delta W 10 to say that the error
has this small a magnitude depends on
the fact that W is a continuously
differentiable function of XY and Z
that's why the theory is so
important what happens in real life is
that most examples you encounter in
engineering
real life engineering the functions that
you're dealing with are continuously
differentiable so it seems like we're
making a big issue over nothing I should
point out that on the frontiers of
knowledge enough situations occur where
the functions that we're dealing with
are not continuously differentiable that
some horrible mistakes can be made by
assuming that you can replace Delta W by
this without any significant error but
as long as this is the case we can do
this
and now notice what does the partial of
W with respect to R mean it means you
take Delta W divided by Delta R and let
me just do that here I'll just divide
every term by Delta R
and now what do I have to do next to get
the partial I have to take the limit as
delta r approaches zero now the
interesting point is as delta r
approaches zero holding s fixed this
term obviously becomes the partial of X
with respect to R by definition this
term becomes the partial of Y with
respect to R by definition and this term
becomes the partial of Z with respect to
R by definition by the way notice that
even though Delta X Delta Y and Delta Z
are all going to 0 as Delta R goes to 0
you cannot immediately conclude that
these terms drop out because after all
Delta R is also approaching 0 so Delta X
over Delta R is that 0 over 0 form in
fact that that's precisely the partial
of X with respect to R term that we're
talking about the beauty is what that as
Delta X Delta Y and Delta Z approach 0
each of the k's approach 0 you see the
reason that these that the error term
becomes negligible becomes 0 in the
limit isn't because Delta X Delta Y and
Delta Z are becoming small because these
small numbers are being divided by
another small number it's because the k1
k2 and k3 are getting small at any rate
putting this all together notice that
now in a manner completely analogous to
our part 1 treatment of the chain rule
except that we're now dealing with
several variables these 3 terms drop out
and these three terms become the claim
that we made before in other words this
is how the partial of W with respect to
R is computed and again the theory is
the easiest part of this that's the easy
part the hard part is getting
familiarity with how to work with this
and I think the best way to get some
familiarity for working with this is to
pick particularly simple problems for
the lecture problems where it's so easy
to do the problem both ways that no hang
up can possibly occur let's take a very
simple example let's suppose that W
equals x squared plus y squared plus Z
squared suppose we also know that X is R
plus s why is our minus s and Z happens
to be to our in this particular
case notice that we would find the
partial of W with respect to our very
conveniently by direct substitution
namely we simply replace X by r plus s
we replace Y by our minus s we replace Z
by two R and then W simply becomes this
expression here which when we collect
terms become 6r squared plus 2's squared
and again the arithmetic there is simple
enough so I'm not even want to bother
worrying about how we justify these
steps at which stage to take the partial
of W with respect to R holding s
constant this is simply 1/12
R because s is being treated as a
constant its derivative with respect to
R is 0 you see notice in an example like
this one would not really be tempted to
use the chain rule the chain rule is
used in many cases not just for
convenience but in cases of great theory
where you're only given that w is some
function of XY and Z and you're not told
explicitly what the function is you're
just given f of X Y Z in the case where
X Y where the function is given
explicitly it's sometimes very easy to
substitute directly at any rate what the
chain rule says is roughly this they say
look at from this equation you can
immediately say the partial of W with
respect to X is 2x the partial of W with
respect to Y is 2y the partial of W with
respect to Z is 2 Z from this equation
you can immediately say that the partial
of X with respect to R is 1 the partial
of X with respect to s is 1 the partial
of Y with respect to R is 1 the partial
of Y with respect to s is minus 1 the
partial of Z with respect to R is 2 and
the partial of Z with respect to s is 0
in particular summarizing our results we
have these here now what the chain rule
says is what to find the partial of W
with respect to R you just take the
partial of W with respect to x times the
partial of X with respect to R plus the
partial of W with respect to Y times the
partial of Y with respect to R plus the
partial of
w with respect to Z times the partial of
Z with respect to R and if we do that in
this case we simply get what 2x plus 2y
plus 4z now again just I pick
deliberately a very simple problem here
remember by definition X is r plus s Y
is our minus s and Z happens to be 2 R
and now you can see very quickly here
that when I substitute in I get what 2 R
plus 2 hours for R + 8 r is 12 R + 2 s -
2 s is 0 the partial of W with respect
to R is also 12 are also meaning what we
found that same answer before at least
that's how the chain rule works and
again we have to remember that the chain
rule does not depend on the number of
variables even though this may start to
look a little bit sticky let's would it
as follows suppose W happens to be a
continuously differentiable function of
the N independent variables x1 up to xn
see that's what this parenthetical
remark means I'm saying that not only do
the partials of F with respect to X 1 up
to xn exist at a given point but they
are continuous there and why do I want
that in there so I can say that my error
term is never any greater than that K 1
Delta X 1 plus K 2 Delta X 2 plus
etcetera KN Delta X n where the case
goes to 0 as the Delta X is equal to 0
I'm going to spare you the details of
proofs but I just want you to keep
seeing why these things are necessary at
any rate let's suppose now that each of
the N variables X 1 up to xn turn out to
be functions of the M variables and an M
could conceivably be equal but M could
even be more than n it can be less than
n there's no reason why they have to be
equal always saying is speaking in the
most general terms suppose each of the N
X's is a continuously differ
a function of the M independent
variables y sub 1 up to Y sub M in fact
that's what this etc means here the etc
refers to the parenthetical remark here
I mean that not only are the X's
functions of y1 up to Y M but they're
continuously differentiable functions
now obviously what we're saying is that
if the double if W can be expressed in
terms of the X's the X's can be
expressed in terms of the Y's obviously
then W can be expressed in terms of the
Y's in other words W is some function of
y1 up to Y M now the question that comes
up is that just looking at this I can
talk about the partial of W with respect
to Y 1 the partial of W with respect to
Y 2 the partial of W with respect to Y 3
etc all the way up to the partial of W
with respect to Y sub M and the question
is look at from the original form of W
it was easy to talk about the partials
of W with respect to the X's from how
the X's are given in terms of the Y's
it's easy to talk about the derivatives
of the X's with respect to the Y's and
so the question is how do you find the
partial of W with respect to say Y sub 1
given all of these other partial
derivatives and the answer again is
something that you just have to get used
to the proof goes through for N and M
the same way as it did for the lower
dimensional case and the intuitive
interpretation is the same namely to
find the partial of W with respect to y
1 we simply see how much W change with
respect to Y 1 due to the change in X 1
alone and on to that the change in W
with respect to Y 1 due to the change in
X 2 alone etc add on to that finally the
change in W with respect to X sub n do
the change in W with respect to Y sub 1
due to the change in X sub n alone in
other words again if you think of this
in terms of cancellation if you cross
these things out don't think of adding
them but think of them as what giving
you the individual components that tell
you how the partial of
w with respect to why one is made up by
the way there is one parenthetical
remark that I haven't written on the
board that I would like to make at this
time in professor Thomas's text he has
elected to introduce matrix algebra
prior to this particular chapter it
again turns out that one does not need
matrices to talk about the chain rule
but that if one had matrix notation the
matrix notation is particularly
convenient for summarizing the chain
rule I have elected to hold off on
matrix algebra till the near future
because it comes up in a much more
better motivated way I think in terms of
these linear approximations but the
point is if as you're reading the text
you see the matrix notation and you are
not familiar with the matrices forget it
all the matrix is is a shortcut notation
for saying this and if I want to
shortcut notation here
I don't need matrices for saying this I
can say this in terms of our Sigma
notation notice that one other way of
writing this thing very compactly that
may be more suggestive is the following
notice that I'm adding up n terms here
the each term consists of two factors
each of which is looks like a fraction
the numerator of the first fraction is
always Delta W a partial of W the
denominator of the second fraction as
always the partial Y one and it appears
that the denominator of the first and
the numerator of the second always have
the same subscript but they seem to vary
consecutively from one to N and that's
precisely where the Sigma notation comes
in handy why don't we just write
therefore that this is the sum partial
of W with respect to X sub K plus the
partial of X sub K with respect to Y 1
as the subscript K ranges through all
integral values from 1 to n in other
words notice that in this particular
form we have simply rewritten this thing
compactly but if you look at this and
look at this I think it's very
suggestive to
see how the chain rule works you see
here's your partial of W with respect to
y 1 and these are what the contributions
do to each of the changes of the end
variable this is the change due to the X
sub K variable right and you add these
all up because they're independent
variables as K goes from 1 to N and I
write etc here simply to point out that
I could have computed the partial of W
with respect to Y 2 instead of Y sub 1
by the way the recipe would have looked
exactly the same except if there was a 2
here there would have been a 2 here if
there were 3 here there would have been
a 3 here if there were an M here there
would have been an M here okay now look
at this particular stage of our lecture
today this could end with the idea that
for the unit that's now assigned this is
as far as you have to go in other words
for the exercises that I've given you in
this particular unit we do nothing
higher than using the chain rule for
first order derivatives the point is
that in many applications in real life
we must take higher-order derivatives in
other words there are many differential
equations partial differential equations
where we must work with higher-order
derivatives and for that reason it
becomes very important sometimes to be
able to take a second derivative or a
third derivative or a fourth derivative
by means of the chain rule now the
interesting point is that the theory
that we've used so far doesn't change at
all what does happen is that the average
student in learning this material for
the first time gets swamped by the
notation consequently what I want to do
is to give you the lecture on this
material at the same time that I'm
lecturing on first order derivatives
simply because the continuity follows
smoothly this way so to see what the
whole overall picture is then to make
sure to cement these things down the
next unit after this will give you drill
on taking higher-order derivatives what
this may mean is that many of you may
prefer
to watch this half of the tape a second
of the film a second time after you've
already tried working some of the
problems with hired or the derivatives
if you're still confused by this but at
any rate let's take a look at a
hypothetical situation since we're so
used to polar coordinates let's talk in
terms of polar coordinates suppose W
happens to be a continuously
differentiable function of x and y x and
y in turn are differentiable e
continuously differentiable functions of
the polar coordinates R and theta in
fact their x equals R cosine theta y
equals our sine theta
now look at if all I want to do is find
the partial of W with respect to R I can
do that by the ordinary chain rule
namely it's the partial of W with
respect to x times the partial of X with
respect to R plus the partial of W with
respect to Y times the partial of Y with
respect to R now knowing what X looks
like explicitly in terms of our and
theta and what Y looks like explicitly
in terms of R and theta
I can certainly compute the partials of
X and Y with respect to R holding theta
constant in particular the partial of X
with respect to R is simply cosine theta
and the partial of Y with respect to R
is simply sine theta so the partial of W
with respect to R is partial of W with
respect to x times cosine theta plus
partial of W with respect to Y times
sine theta and by the way notice that I
cannot simplify these terms
I cannot simplify these terms in general
because all I'm given is that W is some
function of x and y I don't know what W
looks like explicitly in terms of X and
Y so all I can do is talk about the
partials of W with respect to X partial
of W with respect to Y without worrying
any more about this with the
understanding that if I knew what W look
like explicitly in terms of X and Y I
could work out what this thing was
here's the key point
that's why I've accented it in the same
way that W was a function of both x and
y so also are the partials of W with
respect to X and the partial of W with
respect to Y
in other words even though this looks
like this emphasizes the ex notice that
in general when you take the derivative
of a function of both x and y with
respect to X in general the resulting
function will again be a function of
both x and y and so what we're saying is
that if the partials of W with respect
to X and the partial of W with respect
to Y also happen to be continuously
differentiable functions of X and y we
could if we wished use the chain rule
again in other words suppose in the
particular problem that I was dealing
with it wasn't enough to know the
partial of W with respect to R suppose
for example I wanted the second partial
of W with respect to R well obviously
that simply means what take the partial
of this with respect to R in other words
the second partial of W with respect to
R is just the partial of the partial of
W with respect to R with respect to R
I'm just going to differentiate this
thing with respect to R in other words
writing this out more succinctly for you
the second partial derivative of W with
respect to R is the partial with respect
to R of cosine theta partial of W with
respect to X plus sine theta partial of
W with respect to Y now here's the key
point when we differentiate here we're
assuming that theta is being held
constant isn't that right so
consequently when I'm differentiating
with respect to R cosine theta is a
constant I can skip over that C and
differentiate what's left with respect
to R in other words that's what it's the
partial of W with respect to X
differentiated with respect to R see I'm
using the ordinary rule for the river
sum now the derivative of sine theta C
sine theta is a constant with respect to
R so the derivative of this term is just
sine theta times the derivative of the
partial of W with respect to Y with
respect to R written this way now the
key point is that both of these
functions here both of these
functions of x and y x and y in turn are
functions of r and theta so in other
words to differentiate this thing with
respect to r i must use the chain rule
again now because this may seem
difficult for you all I'm really saying
is look at if this term here looks messy
since we know it the partial of W with
respect to X is some function of x and y
let's call that H of X Y then all we're
saying is that the partial of the
partial of the partial of W with respect
to X with respect to R is just the
partial of H with respect to R but to
find the partial of H with respect to R
we know how to use the chain rule there
it's just what it's the partial of H
with respect to x times the partial of X
with respect to R plus the partial of H
with respect to Y times the partial of Y
with respect to R of course if we now
remember what the partial of what H's CH
is the partial of W with respect to X so
if I differentiate with that again with
respect to X I get the second partial of
W with respect to X we've already seen
that the partial of X with respect to R
is cosine theta so I have this term the
partial of H with respect to Y really
says what differentiate the partial of W
with respect to X with respect to Y and
the usual way of abbreviating that is
like this which again is explained in
the reading material and we now multiply
that by the partial of Y with respect to
R which happens to be sine theta now
look at this a few times in your spare
time if it's bothering you it is not
really that difficult it is messy
notation in the sense that you're not
used to notation that's quite that messy
that's why it's messy that once you get
used to it it is not any tougher than
the chain rule for one independent
variable in fact to take the partial of
the partial of W with respect to Y with
respect to R I'll do that in one step
without using a substitution all I'm
saying is that this function depends
on both x and y so to see what its
derivative isn't respect to R I'll see
what the contribution of its derivative
respect to R is due to just X along then
I'll see what contribution of its
derivative with respect to R is due to
just Y along and by the way when I say
it that way notice how quick it is to
write this thing down I differentiate
this with respect to X multiplied by the
partial of X with respect to R add on to
that the partial of this with respect to
Y multiply that by the partial of Y with
respect to R if I do this notice now I
have what I have the partial with
respect to Y and I differentiate that
with respect to X that's written this
way and by the way notice that this is
the reverse order of what we did over
here namely in one case we first
differentiate with respect to X and then
with respect to Y in the other case we
differentiated first with respect to Y
and then with respect to X so it
actually conceptually there is a
difference that's why we write these
things if these things differently it
does again turn out that in most cases
the answer that you get thank goodness
doesn't depend on the order in which you
perform the derivatives but this is not
at all self-evident even though you'd
like to believe that it is but we'll
talk about that more in the exercises
and the like but all I'm saying now is
that if we put everything together of
what we've had before we can obtain in
this particular case that the second
partial of W with respect to R is this
somewhat messy but nonetheless
straightforward expression and see I've
circled these things to sort of tell you
that if it is permissible to interchange
the order of differentiation we could
combine these two terms on the other
hand if you couldn't interchange the
order this would be a rather dangerous
thing to do over here because these
might be different answers as I say
again if you have enough continuity it
turns out that these two factors are the
same but that's not the important issue
here the important issue here is that I
can keep using the chain rule
to take higher-order derivatives and
even though the notation is Messier this
happened when we dealt with functions of
a single variable remember when we use
the chain rule to differentiate to find
dy/dx we're not when y and X were given
say as functions of T we could also use
the chain rule to find the second
derivative of Y with respect to X but we
had to be a little bit more careful of
the computation because certain factors
crept in that we had to keep track of
at any rate again to illustrate this
idea rather than to keep droning on
about it let me take a particularly
simple computational problem to check
this thing on in other words what I'm
going to do is take this messy formula
over here and apply it to a case where
the arithmetic happens to be very very
simple I'm going to rig this very very
nicely I'm going to let f of XY just be
x squared plus y squared in this case
let W be x squared plus y squared in
polar coordinates notice that x squared
plus y squared is just R squared so the
puck so W is just R squared what is the
partial of W with respect to R then the
partial of W with respect to R is 2r and
if I now differentiate that with respect
to R the second partial of W with
respect to R is 2 obviously one would
not use the chain rule in real life to
find the answer to this particular
problem we've chosen this problem simply
to emphasize how the chain rule would
work here at any rate going back here
notice that it's very simple to see from
this equation that the partial of W with
respect to X is 2x therefore the second
partial of W respect to X is 2 the
partial of W with respect to Y is 2y
therefore the second partial of W with
respect to Y is also 2 the partial of W
with respect to X as a function of X
alone in this case consequently the
derivative respect to Y will be 0
similarly the partial of W with respect
to Y is a function of Y alone
consequently when I differentiate that
with respect to X meaning I'm holding Y
constant that derivative will also be 0
and the interesting point now is if I
take the
values and substitute those into this
equation what happens look at the second
partial of W with respect to X is just 2
the second partial of W with respect to
Y is just to the mixed partials
are both 0 regardless of which order you
did them in that's what we saw over here
so consequently according to this recipe
the second partial of W with respect to
R is 2 cosine squared theta plus 0 plus
2 sine squared theta plus 0 where the
reason that I've written these zeros in
is simply so that when you're looking at
your notes later that traces the analog
of these terms over here at any rate
notice now that if I add these up to
cosine squared theta plus 2 sine squared
theta since sine squared theta plus
cosine squared theta is 1 this sum is
just I'll write that in white shark just
so we don't accentuate it let's just be
part of the answer this is 2 plus 0
which is 2 and this certainly does check
with the result that we got the
so-called easier way and again I don't
want to leave you with the idea that the
second way was just a hard way of doing
the same problem that we did easily the
first way well I picked a simple example
so you can see how this works I'm going
to have a multitude of exercises for you
to do in the next unit simply so that
you pick up the kind of know-how that
will allow you to change variables using
the chain rule with a minimum degree of
difficulty in fact hopefully I would
like to feel by the time we're through
with the next two units you will be
doing this almost as second nature well
we have other topics to consider in
terms of our linear approximations and
the like we'll talk about that more as
the course unfolds for the time being I
would like you to concentrate simply on
mastering the chain rule and so until we
meet next time goodbye
funding for the public
this video was provided by the Gabriella
and Paul Rosenbaum foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate